[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour de nouveau parler de strangers inc
malheureusement la saison 4 a été mis en
pause pour son tournage à cause des
évènements actuels mais c'est tout à
fait compréhensible
je suppose que vous vous doutez bien
pourquoi nous nous retrouvons
aujourd'hui toute façon vous l'avez vu
sur la miniature est dans le titre
nous allons parler du cas de hopper mon
dieu ce que ce débat était rude et nous
en avons enfin la réponse
netflix n'a pas du tout hésité une seule
seconde pour montrer un court trailer
rien que pour donner cette information
hopper est vivant et a survécu
maintenant on le sait mais qu'est ce qui
va en découler de tout ça et bien pour
le moment
tout concorde avec ce qui a été prévu
comme proposé dans l'ancien teaser ne
sommes plus à hawkins et cela a son
importance beaucoup d'entre nous
hésitions à 6 cette phrase connoté avec
le déménagement des bailleurs et televen
ou si cela traités justement de la
menace grand-tante des russes manipulant
les portails de l'ops taille down à
kamtchatka il est évident qu'aujourd'hui
cette phrase se tourner vers la seconde
option et tout particulièrement par
rapport à hopper sans avoir la
confirmation de sa survie il était
difficile d'annoncer que strangers wings
saison 4 tournerait beaucoup plus dans
des décors de russie alors qu'aucun des
personnages principaux né là bas
hopper va donc pouvoir servir de point
de repère pour nous spectateurs dans ces
contrées enneigées
également je pense que nous pouvons
presque l'a clamé à 100% mais il est
évident qu peur et l'américain détenus
de la scène post générique du dernier
épisode de la saison 3 bref tout
concorde avec la survie dopeurs et la
cohérence de ce qui nous a été montrée
cependant comment hopper s'est il
retrouvé ici
et surtout qu'est ce que cela prévoit
pour la suite
concernant la survie docteur tout peut
être possible hopper était prêt à se
sacrifier devant le deuil ce pour que
cette dernière puisse fermer le portail
et tué le mind flyers l'explosion en
elle-même a pu téléporter hopper dans le
portail le
dans tout droit en russie mais dans la
cohérence des images bas nous voyons des
russes explosé ça fait le très bizarre
de dire ça
bref pourquoi eux et n'ont pas peur la
possibilité que je vois personnellement
et qu'il y a eu une coupure voulu dans
l'épisode entre le moment où joyce
active l'explosion de la machine et le
moment de l'explosion
encore aujourd'hui je ne vois pas de
raison sensée de mettre cette coupure à
part pour souligner quelque chose un
temps où hopper a pu courir jusqu'au
portail pour survivre si nous regardons
bien la scène
hopper et joy semble séparer par une
sorte de barrière électrique que crée la
machine ne pouvant faire machine arrière
hopper a pu se glisser dans le portail
rapidement avec l'explosion et cela
expliquerait la coupure au beurre ce
serait donc retrouver dans l'occident
avec pour seule sortie comme chaque cas
peut être que les portails sont reliés
mais bref nous avons déjà parlé
plusieurs fois de tout ça là où
j'aimerais vous a mené aujourd'hui et
cantal intrigue tournant autour de la
survie dopeurs et comment la situation
va pouvoir se débloquer ce que je trouve
fascinant avec strangers tings c'est le
changement de point de vue par
génération nous avons le point de vue
des enfants pré ados avec mike will et
tout le groupe
ensuite nous avons le point de vue des
vieux adolescents entre guillemets ou
jeunes adultes avec 96 et johnatan par
exemple et enfin nous avons le point de
vue des adultes avec joyce et les autres
et bien que chaque point de vue restent
assez équivalent dans chaque saison
l'importance de chaque personnage est
modifié en fonction de l'avancement de
l'histoire nous avons beaucoup de
protagonistes à l'écran il est normal
que certains deviennent plus pertinents
et inversement
nous en avons l'exemple avec will
personnage au centre de l'intrigué mais
absent de la saison une beaucoup plus
important dans la saison 2 est presque
mis de côté dans la saison 3 je pense
que vous commencez à vous demander
l'heure où je souhaite vous menez et
bien par le biais de la saison 3 nous
pouvons déterminer des choses qui
arriveront dans la saison 4 et
l'importance de certains personnages
dont
en particulier la saison 3 mis en place
une sorte de trinité elle a installé un
triangle qui va nous servir pour cette
saison 4 je parle bien évidemment de
hopper à joyce et le personnage clé
murray boma si les show runner ont
décidé de mettre ces personnages
ensemble et de les faire avancer
réunis au milieu de toutes les intrigues
ce n'est pas pour rien murray bowman
était presque quasiment un figurant un
rôle très peu d'impact en dans les deux
premières saisons et par le biais de ces
troisièmes le personnage est passé de
petits rôles à rôle principal et je
pense à fond que nous ne sommes pas au
bout de nos surprises
je m'explique le triangle joyce hopper
et murray est très important étant des
adultes confirmés ils servent de points
de contrôle et de repères pour les
enfants car même si f possède de grands
pouvoirs et est entre guillemets la
protagoniste principal est bien cela
reste une enfant qui a besoin de son
papa adoptif hopper est ce que je vous
dis c'est pareil pour les autres
s'il ya le moindre problème on se
tournera toujours vers hopper ou joyce
maintenant que vous avez compris l'idée
le triangle va énormément avoir son
importance dans la saison 4
la menace est en russie avait copper
prisonniers des russes à kamtchatka
joyce elle va emménager dans sa nouvelle
maison avec ses enfants et elle puis
murray sera le dernier lien nous
permettant d'avoir une vision à hawkins
mais pas que j'aimerais que vous vous
rappelez du fameux numéro qui permettait
d'atterrir sur la messagerie demeurait
ce dernier nous disait qu'il fallait
arrêter de l'appeler etc mais que si
c'était joyce
il fallait qu'ils revoient en personne
car il avait fait une découverte pas
forcément bonnes ni mauvaises mais une
découverte
ensuite j'aimerais vous rappeler que
murray est un personnage avec énormément
de ressources ce dernier est un
détective il a des connaissances sur
beaucoup de choses concernant les
gouvernements et j'en passe et le plus
important ce dernier par le russe on ne
connaît malheureusement encore que peu
de choses sur le passé de murray mais si
ce dernier par le russe sait qu'il doit
y avoir une raison je vous le mets en
mille le dernier va retrouver la trace
de hopper par le biais de possibles
contacts en russie où peut-être une
infiltration dans son gouvernement
je vous le rappelle murray était
convaincu depuis le début que les russes
étaient infiltrés à hawkins depuis la
saison une et ce dernier avait raison
alors que personne ne le croyait il est
obligé que ce dernier ayant perdu hopper
et joyce soit parti en russie pour mener
son enquête et trouvé des pistes quant à
ce que les russes faisait au beau milieu
dawkins ce serait là bas qu'il pourrait
faire une découverte sur les travaux des
russes et souhaiterait en parler à joyce
ne comprenant pas encore réellement ce
qu'ils font car ce dernier n'a pas
conscience de tout ce qui touche à
l'aube saïda en quart murray n'a jamais
été mise en contact avec le mind flyers
ou un démon gorgon par exemple la saison
3 nous l'a prouvé murray c'est
s'infiltrer parmi les russes communiquer
avec eux et koné bizarrement leurs
coutumes et se pourrait que ce dernier
en sache beaucoup plus que l'on pourrait
le penser et qu'il est même un lien avec
eux peut-être était-il un russe avant de
devenir américain je vous le demande
dans tous les cas murray est la clé de
la libération d'opr je suis prêt à
mettre ma main à couper
mais vous qu'est ce que vous pensez tout
ça et quels sont vos avis dites le moi
en commentaire je suis curieux de vous
lire j'espère vraiment que la vidéo vous
aura plu cela fait du bien de se changer
les idées au vu des circonstances
actuelles et on parle de strangers
things quand même ça fait grave du bien
n'oubliez pas en tout cas le petit bleu
c'est très important si vous souhaitez
me soutenir
j'ai remarqué d'ailleurs que beaucoup
d'entre vous regardez les vidéos sans
être abonné c'est le moment de le faire
c'est gratuit et cela vous permettra de
ne louper aucune autre sur ce je fonce
vous préparer d'autres théories sur
strangers tings ou d'autres sujets que
le 'lion' earth soit avec vous